we are alienated intellectuals
i mean broadly speaking this is what we
are we are
alienated intellectuals and so we [ __ ]
about the government and we critique the
monetary system and so forth and so on
well then you see your children on the
brink of reason
and you say you know geez
my alien nation has brought me
alienation
but i can't let the kids grow up to be
marks to be uh pawns of the market
economy and the propaganda machine
people scratching their heads trying to
figure out whether they're republicans
or democrats
i can't put that on my children
and so then you say well okay then
they must join in the alien nation
they must be taken out of the culture as
we were taken
out of the culture and this is a
momentous decision
because you this act of separating
from the culture is unambiguously
alienating and yet it seems to be the
only way to
find the self otherwise you never
contact the self
you contact a commodified cartoon
of the self that finds meaning in
outboard
motors and to basketball
and you know all this other crap
that's peddled as reality so
our relationship to our culture i think
is a very uncomfortable
one and of course psychedelics
exacerbate this
and you know i think if you have
children that it's one thing to talk
alienation but once they get to the
place where they're asking to take
lsd or to take phil simon then
you know kafka said a wonderful thing i
think it's in the penal colony he said
you can choose to be free but it's the
last
choice you'll ever make
and you know that's that's sort of the
dilemma in which we find ourselves
that's all folks
you